le gouvernement legault continue
d'essuyer les critiques concernant son
projet de loi 61 qui doit permettre de
relancer l'économie en accélérant les
projets d'infrastructures les partis
d'opposition les groupes
environnementaux et le comité de suivi
de la commission charbonneau ont de
sérieuses réserves
québec veut faciliter les expropriations
accélérée et l'octroi des contrats et
alléger le processus d' analyses
environnementales avec nous ce soir
jacques létourneau président de la csn
on rejoindra également dans quelques
instants le pdg de la fédération des
chambres de commerce du québec jacques
létourneau bonsoir dont sont friands est
ce que le gouvernement a votre avis va
trop vite veut aller trop vite dans ce
dossier retrouve définitivement surtout
avec son échéancier d'adopter si la fin
de la semaine le projet de loi 61 et
nous hier en commission parlementaire on
a même été jusqu'à dire le gouvernera
pas besoin d'adopter pl 61 pour lancer
son plan d'infrastructures dans le cadre
de la relance dans la mesure où c'était
déjà dans les cartons
ces projets d'infrastructure lors de la
4 lors des dernières élections et lors
du dernier budget du québec on aurait
intérêt justement cette volonté-là de
financer le programme des
infrastructures au québec
donc on ne comprend pas pourquoi le
gouvernement non seulement veut
accélérer le processus en garde vitesse
et en plus et en plus maintenant l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
pour l'éviter nous on pense que ça va
pas du tout alors ce qu'il y a urgence
parce qu'il y avait urgence d'agir parce
qu'il y à 13 7% de chômage au québec
concernant une année économique
épouvantable c'est pas à l'état
justement devenir stimuler l'économie et
d'aller plus vite
nous on est favorable avec une idée de
relancer une partie de l'économie par
les infrastructures maintenant le
problème c'est quand on regarde le
projet de loi le pied des juristes si
vous l'avez même dit tantôt dans
l'introduction
les gens là qui ont suivi la commission
charbonneau donc qui lève des drapeaux
rouges anti ça attention accélérée est
une chose mais contourner la
réglementation se donner des pouvoirs
extraordinaires justement pour
contourner les règlements en
environnement de contourner les
processus d'appel d'offres écoutez même
dans le projet de loi là on donne les
moyens au gouvernement du québec par
exemple de continuer avec des arrêtés
ministériels pourrait oser des nouvelles
conditions travail nous ont dicté l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
ça peut peut-être se défendre nous ça
faisait pas notre affaire quand on nous
faisait poser des arrêtés ministériels
dans un contexte de crise est vitale
comme celui qu'on a connu en marbre or
une telle offre sérieuse mais on est
dans un période de déconfinement oui on
a besoin de projets structurants
les infrastructures sont une chose mais
il manque quand même des choses
importantes des pans entiers de notre
économie sont pas non plus couvert par
payer 70 ans alors chars milliards se
joint à nous pdg de la fédération des
chambres de commerce du québec bonsoir
nombreux ça va on est habitué la 206 est
ce que c'est trop rapide pour vous ce
projet de loi où l'urgence d'urgence
économique justifie qu'on accélère des
projets et qu'on aille assez rapidement
avec l'adoption de ce projet de loi
bah écoutez je pense que la réponse est
un peu dans le milieu j'entendais
monsieur les pour ne mentionner que il
ya plein de choses qui sont pas dans
quoi je dois je pense qu'il faut étudier
le projet de loi pour ce qu'il est à
dire un plan pour favoriser la les
infrastructures un peu partout au québec
avec 202 projets et d'avoir des mesures
donc permettent d'accélérer les
processus administratifs alors c'est
pour le plan de relance du gouvernement
donc dans ce sens là moi je pense que
c'est une heure on parle en fait à la
fédération que sait faire quoi que ce
soit qui est intéressant mais il est
perfectible
alors j'entends les critiques beaucoup
depuis plusieurs jours il ya personne
ici dans la communauté d'affaires qui
tient le dire il veut retourner une
période où la commission charbonneau
mais est ce qu il pas justement un
danger d'aller là d'accélérer l'octroi
de contourner certaines règles et de de
voir ressurgir et réapparaître des
possibilités de collusion et de
corruption
je pense que plein mécanisme qui était
pas ma place à les portes sont en place
maintenant l'autorité des marchés
publics le travail le vérificateur
général est très important puis arrêt
des parlementaires aussi si tout le
monde
eto'o 6 et 2 aussi obsédé par sa
situation à juste titre on va tous
pouvoir jouer notre rôle et je pense que
le premier mini je suis pas là pour
défendre le gouvernement le premier
ministre a dit que je trouvais que
l'image était belle on veut pas réduire
les existe les exigences on veut réduire
les délais et je peux pas croire que
quelqu'un au québec parce que ya pas de
l'efficience dans les délais qui peut
être amélioré et d'accord et jijel
tournent ô toi moi je fais un peu
allergique à cette approche dans la
mesure où on présente toujours le taux
québécois où l'état canadien comme étant
des et alo'o technocratique
bureaucratique ya des règles dans notre
société quand on parle de questions
environnementales par exemple dans le
projet on va quasiment aussi loin que
changer la nature du ministère de
l'environnement pour en faire un
promoteur des projets d'infrastructures
un instant non moi je pense que
guillaume moyens effectivement de mettre
les bouchées doubles pour permettre la
mise en chantier de ces projets là sans
suspendre les formats de notre état de
droit et les principes qui régissent
notre démocratie donc je le répète nous
ne projets d'infrastructures on est
favorable nous en pensons le même dit au
premier ministre monsieur legault le 1er
mai puis à monsieur dubé nous a demandé
des efforts au niveau de la construction
c'est une crise de la main d'oeuvre d'un
secteur de la construction quand bien
même en partie serrée tout si ce projet
là demain matin là au mois de juillet
pour construire des maisons des aînés
qui prolonger la ligne bleue puis qui
construit des tramways
on en demande donc le premier rennaise
de divorce fin des efforts au niveau de
la formation de la main-d'oeuvre ça donc
la lourdeur administrative
bureaucratique ça existe mais
sérieusement la puissance des droits
fondamentaux et surtout été tiré de
l'eau mais est-ce que même si l'objectif
des chars milliards que le gouvernement
profite de l'occasion pour accélérer
certains certaines balises administratif
justement au réglementaire qui existent
pour aller plus vite sur ces projets là
puisse dire ben voilà il ya une crise on
profite de la situation on voit plus
rapidement mais je touche écoutez je
trouve ça un peu méprisant pour pour la
communauté d'affaires puis pour le
gouvernent là bas je dois vous dire de
passer
tout le monde veut s'esquiver les délais
des exigences complet à voir dans des
projets alors je pense qu à poussan
monsieur létourneau est là mais n'est
pas si loin que ça je pense qu'on
reconnaît que le boarder certaines
lourdeurs administratives et c'est pas
un disco et nouveau depuis la pandémie
syndicaux qui existe depuis longtemps
qu'on pense payer certains projets
prennent de l'eau dans le gaz avant
d'avoir lieu au québec
l'occasion est bonne si c'est bien
balisé il ya des amendements sont
possibles en jeu j'ai fait une liste des
amendements lequel qui sont discutées en
clôture sur la durée donc de l'urgence
sanitaire de 2 h sur la portée de la sec
50 par la loi tant que plein de choses
je pense que les parlements
alors avec dans les prochaines semaines
mais vous pourrez pas faire dire que
c'est pas une bonne idée d'accélérer la
croissance économique au québec avec des
projets comme celui là s'ils sont bien
balisé car si bonne idée messieurs
létourneau d'accélérer la croissance
économique avec ce plan de relance
nous on va préférer le développement et
la croissance plutôt que l'austérité
sociale sur toutes les tenues
le ministre des finances va nous avons
signé un tout qu'on est dans une
situation d'endettement épouvantable
soyez pas de doute là dessus
mais quand nous on parle d'une vision
par rapport à la question du
développement économique et même des
projets d'infrastructure va vous donner
un exemple en date lors d'un congé 61
les maisons des aînés on nous dit c'est
la solution partout au québec et à
montréal on renouvelle dch sld alors que
c'est là qu'on ne lui l'épicentre de la
crise sanitaire chez des personnes âgées
y une incohérence que quelque chose qui
marche pas de la sonde et paris merci
beaucoup jacques létourneau et charles
milliards d'avoir été là de justesse
également merci bien merci